[Music]
breaking news this monday night
closing in on the cause of the
catastrophe that engulfed
linton bc new details on the rcmp's
investigation
it's human cost while destructive
wildfires devour america's west coast
racism against england's black players
unforgivable really
and the accusations of hypocrisy against
the british government
sharing the wealth for other people's
health canada's donation of unused coven
vaccines
plus it's not child's play
the record-smashing sale for this
vintage video game
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin tonight with the
wild heat and the wildfires in the west
it's the front line of the climate
crisis in north america right now
from british columbia to california
unprecedented searing temperatures and
bone-dry conditions
have turned parts of the west coast into
a tinderbox
more than 300 wildfires are burning in
b.c more than 28 percent of them
are deemed to be out of control and
there are 25 fires of note
these are highly visible and pose a
threat to public safety
now look at the situation south of the
border these are all the active
wildfires in the western states
the largest fires in that region have
engulfed more than 300
000 hectares of land we'll get to that
in a moment but first there's breaking
news out of bc
where the rcmp has revealed more details
about the investigation into the linton
fire
that destroyed 90 percent of the village
global's julia foy is here with the
latest from the rcmp
julia well rob the rcmp have been on the
scene in linton since the town burnt
down the evening of june the 30th
so for 12 days they say they've been
collecting physical
digital and forensic evidence today we
learned that they're looking at two
areas of interest as to how the fire may
have started and in which
location it's important for any police
investigation not to get tunnel vision
and not to and quickly jump to
conclusions we need to
uh um go along follow our investigative
path as the evidence leads us
and that's what we're going to do in
this case now we know that the litten
fire
didn't actually get underway and came to
officials notice until around 5
30 that evening the evacuation order was
issued
at 6 00 pm we know of course that two
people
died in the fire the rcmp are saying
that they have found
many of the reported missing people and
they're safe
they're still not ready to say that
there are no
other fatalities until they reach out to
the public
and this is just one of several
investigations that are currently going
on to the cause of the fire
the bc wild fire service as well as the
coroner and the transportation
safety board are all looking for answers
robin julia foy reporting tonight thanks
julia
in the western u.s there are fears this
fire season has the potential to outpace
2020 the worst on record and after
another weekend of excessive heat
there's little relief here's jennifer
johnson
blistering high temperatures bone dry
terrain and
out of control fires are burning up
america's west from oregon to arizona
oregon's bootleg fire is now the largest
in the country in arizona two
firefighters were killed when their
plane crashed while surveying flames
and in california raging fires are
swallowing up homes
devastating communities four dogs i
think they're gone
i couldn't get them out they couldn't
see this latest heat wave coming after
parts of the u.s southwest
experienced the hottest june on record
experts say
climate change is to blame we're just
going to constantly see
over time increases in our average
temperature
and increases in our extremes most
people don't think about heat
as a killer and it is while air
conditioning units strain
debris from the oregon fire is affecting
power lines in northern california which
has already lost a tenth of its power
supply
so this is a big hit we're all going to
do everything
we possibly can to maintain reliability
california's governor has declared a
power grid emergency
asking residents to conserve power and
water lake mead in nevada which supplies
water for
25 million people in los angeles and
across four
states is now at the lowest level it's
been in its 85 year history
and it's only mid july smoke billowing
east from the fires is so intense
even people in utah two states over are
feeling the effects
so you've got the ozone burning the
lines and you have all this
debris that particulates the ash and the
smoke tourists are back in las vegas but
doctors are warning against excessive
drinking
in this excessive heat they need fluid
resuscitation very quickly because the
alcohol has dehydrated them so much
death valley california is one of the
hottest places on earth
i think the best way to describe it is
that moment when you open the oven
and that gust of heat hits you in the
face
this is the second heat wave the west
has seen in a little over two weeks
once again baking and igniting a region
already suffering from extreme drought
jennifer johnson global news washington
in british columbia multiple people are
dead and one person is unaccounted for
after a crane collapsed in downtown
kelowna it happened late this morning at
a construction site
witnesses reported hearing a loud thud
and some
saw it come down the surrounding area
was evacuated and investigators are now
on the scene
trying to figure out what went wrong
now jacova 19 and canada's progress in
getting people vaccinated
as of tonight about 79 of canadians 12
and older have at least one dose and 49
have been fully vaccinated the federal
government says it's in such good shape
with vaccine supplies that it's decided
to donate
17.7 million more astrozenica doses
through the kovacs program to help lower
income countries
at this point there are no plans to
donate pfizer or moderna
and as abigail beeman reports it's still
unclear whether down the road
third doses may be needed the white
house has been clear on a coveted
booster
at this time we don't see the need for
it but
once again the canadian government
response needs parsing and analysis
and can't be summed up in a single
phrase the public health agency of
canada
is doing this work they are doing the
research they are
looking into it as is the vaccine task
force health canada tells global news
pfizer hasn't yet submitted a request to
approve a booster here
but notes in general one may be required
and it's
monitoring the need closely pfizer tells
us it's too early to comment on
potential canadian submissions
but we know it will be applying in the
u.s as for the vaccine task force
there hasn't been any official position
from the task force or
nasty this task force member suspects
they'll say there's not yet clear
evidence a third dose
is necessary but dr andre veyet thinks
some groups could be greenlit
before data is in those who are
immunocompromised or people in long-term
care as israel and france have done do
we need
to wait until they start having
infections there's an ethical dilemma
too the world health organization is
slamming countries prioritizing
third doses over poorer nations without
a first
it doesn't even make any sense if we're
worried about variants which is what we
should be worried about
the variants are increasingly going to
come from those countries
where there's large pools of virus that
is where people have not been vaccinated
canada is trying to strike a balance
assuring there's enough supply at home
if a booster is necessary
and announcing more global support
another 17.7 million doses of
astrazeneca through kovacs
and a matching program through unicef up
to 10 million dollars
first time in 60 years more children
under the age of five
died from preventable causes another
booster complication is the next chapter
in the mix and match vaccine debate the
yet to be approved
novavax and sanofi vaccines are
protein-based
if approved that becomes the third
vaccine technology in the mix
after all canadians will have had access
to the other two
for their first and second doses abigail
beeman global news
ottawa the uk is moving ahead with the
final stage of easing britain's lockdown
despite a spike in infections
starting next monday nearly all
remaining restrictions in england will
be lifted
the government says there will never be
a perfect time to take the step
but believes now is the best time to do
it the prime minister is still urging
people to continue taking
precautions it is absolutely vital
that we proceed now with caution
and i cannot say this powerfully or
emphatically
enough this pandemic
is not over among the changes coming to
the uk next monday
all restrictions on social gatherings
will be removed
and nightclubs can reopen for the first
time since march
2020. british police are investigating
disturbing allegations of racism
following sunday's european championship
final at wembley stadium
italy beat england in a tense penalty
shootout and now the three young english
players who missed
are being targeted with racist abuse
redmond shannon reports
after england's defeat head coach gareth
southgate
would have expected to be fielding
questions about the penalty shootout
i'm incredibly proud of the players but
instead much of the media attention is
focusing on the racism
directed at his players for some of them
to be abused
is unforgivable really prince william
the president of the english football
association says he was
sickened by the racist abuse aimed at
the three players who missed their kicks
to those who have been directing racist
abuse
at some of the players i say shame on
you
and i hope you will crawl back under the
rock from which you
emerged some critics are accusing boris
johnson's government of hypocrisy
before and during the euros a
significant minority of england fans
booed their own players for taking a
knee in the name of racial equality
it's something that boris johnson
hesitated in condemning
his interior minister refused to do so
you saw the government
engaging what can only be called a
cultural war
uh taking a cultural position against
the taking of the knee
and and i think people remember that
because that also gives them some kind
of freedom
to be abusive when it comes to to black
players in particular
former players say this abuse was
predictable
it starts at the very top and so for me
i was i wasn't surprised in the
slightest i woke up this morning to
those headlines i expected it the minute
that the three players that missed
missed
online abuse has dogged english soccer
for years
the uk government is promising
legislation to hold social media giants
to account
unfortunately the social media platforms
have had
a long time to deal with this sort of
problem and and they still
are not doing what they need to do a big
game that began with
such promise for england ending in a
police investigation
and a reminder of why players are taking
a knee
in the first place redmond shannon
global news london
now to a major development in haiti
police say they've captured a man who
they believe helped organize the
assassination of the country's president
the suspect is a 63-year-old who's been
living in florida
mike armstrong has more on the arrest
and the explosive allegations
they are discouraged they have no hope
this
is the man haitian national police say
organized the killing of the president
his name christian emmanuel seno he met
no
police the chief of the police force
called ceno one of the leaders behind
the assassination
he says it was i know who hired and
brought mercenaries into haiti
and that it was ceno that one of those
mercenaries called
immediately after the murder
the chief says seno arrived in haiti at
the beginning of june on a private plane
the men he was with were supposed to be
his personal security
now ceno has had political ambitions
this is a video posted nine years ago as
part of a campaign
i will bring hope to them why i will
bring hope with to them because i see
their sufferings
a twitter account linked to ceno and
that campaign has been deleted
one of its last messages was recent june
7
a call for a transitional government
saying the capital was in complete
chaos the assassination of president
johannes
is driving political tensions even
higher
just two days before he was killed moise
named a new prime minister
the man who was supposed to be replaced
claude joseph is
holding on to power he's also being
recognized as haiti's leader by the
international community
over the weekend representatives from
the u.s were in haiti and met
government officials and opposition
leaders the white house says it's still
studying a request for haiti for troops
to protect infrastructure
and stabilize the country this is just
the beginning of our conversations and
and we will remain in close touch with
law enforcement
with individuals in haiti to further
complicate the crisis
about half of the capital is controlled
by gangs
one of the most powerful gang leaders is
calling on supporters to take to the
streets
and for other gangs to join in at a time
when people are desperate for aid
aid organizations are having to shut
down programs
fearing violence mike armstrong global
news
as if coveted long-haulers don't have
enough to deal with coming up how some
are struggling to make
ends meet
wow it's canada's morning show with jeff
mcarthur
and carolyn mackenzie you
this is huge for canadians coming
together to be an amplified voice
that's big watch the morning show
weekdays on global
[Applause]
canadian tennis star bianca and rescue
won't be going to the tokyo games
because of the ongoing challenges caused
by the pandemic
on instagram the 21 year old says she's
been dreaming of representing team
canada at the olympics
since she was a little girl but knows
deep in her heart
it's the right decision canadians
suffering with long covid are becoming
increasingly worried about their
financial future a new federal report
suggests more than half of patients
might have symptoms that linger
for months azan gaviola reports some
long-haulers looking for help say
they're falling
through the cracks 36-year-old adriana
patino
used to be the picture of health i was a
competitive
swimmer i went to two world
championships with national team
everything i don't have any pre-existing
conditions
now the north vancouver consultant is
among the estimated half a million
people across canada
who either have or had long covid
defined as being sick because of
coronavirus for more than three months
it's just been a nightmare
being close to dying a few times
medically long covid can present as an
invisible illness
there's no single test to identify it
symptoms vary from person to person
with fatigue brain fog and digestive
issues among the common ailments
i would wake up in the middle of the
night and i'm suffocating because i
can't breathe
i would fall down because my heart rate
was
running at 150 bits per minute just
walking from here to the kitchen
pitino has been back and forth with her
insurance company for disability
compensation for three months with
nothing to show for it
patino's grateful for money from friends
who started a gofundme campaign to help
her out
at this point patino says her savings
are drained she's making ends meet with
money borrowed from her mom
i'd go into a room forget that i'd what
i
come for forget people's names and look
at my dogs and
wonder i have three dogs and and not
remember their names or
my son susie golding founded a facebook
support group for long-haulers in canada
with so little information on the
condition she says the group has been a
lifeline to its nearly 14 thousand
members long-haulers face an uphill
battle when it comes to insurance
coverage
being something new it's very right
for insurance companies to
[Music]
come to conclusion well you know there's
insufficient medical evidence in support
of your
of your claim for disability an
extension of employment insurance
benefits from ottawa may help
but even though the federal budget
promised to extend those benefits from
15 weeks to 26
the changes won't likely kick in until
next year a private member's bill is
pushing to extend sickness ei to 50
weeks to help long-haulers
but as politicians decide whether or not
to extend federal support and
compensation from insurance companies
runs out
or is denied long-haulers say they're
slipping through the cracks
i want people to take this seriously and
i want the government to take us
seriously
ann gaviola global news toronto
the desperate move to quell the deadly
violence in south africa
just ahead
cuba's president is blaming rare mass
protests over the weekend on a
well-funded social media campaign and
tough american sanctions tens of
thousands of demonstrators took to the
streets in the biggest anti-government
protest the island has seen in decades
people are angry over food shortages a
resurgence of covet cases
and a slow vaccine rollout calls are
growing for the president to step
down and an end to cuba's communist
dictatorship
the military has been deployed in south
africa to help calm deadly violence
sparked by the jailing of former
president
jacob zuma
at least six people have died and more
than 200 people have been arrested in
rioting and looting
zuma was sentenced to 15 months in
prison for refusing to give evidence at
a corruption inquiry
into his nine-year reign he filed an
appeal
today
up next an unopened copy of a classic
video game pays off
big time remember in the mid 90s when
mario first walked into the world of 3d
and became one of the most popular video
games nintendo ever made
well the craze apparently isn't over on
sunday a sealed super mario
cartridge from 1996 sold for a record
1.5
million dollars u.s the coffee is one of
about
five in mint condition and it's the
first time a game has gone
for over a million bucks real-life
italians are celebrating another big
game
the azure upset of the three lions the
european championship had soccer fans in
canada roaring back to life too
and as mike delay explains with pandemic
restrictions easing
sport is bringing people back together
the joke in toronto is if you want to
know if italy is playing football
you only have to listen there's just
something unique and loud
okay passionate about the way italians
celebrate the beautiful game
[Applause]
it's safe to say wherever the azure
faithful gathered like here in vancouver
or in montreal's large italian community
la dolce vita or the good life
was in full swing and it was refreshing
because for most of the past 16 months
the pandemic has suppressed that love of
life
and toronto's normally vibrant little
italy wasn't immune to the financial
pressures
brought on by covid so it was pretty
devastating for us and
we really feared for our future because
like many we didn't really know what was
going to happen and we sort of took
it day by day but as each day progressed
it got worse and worse
for 53 years cafe diplomatico has been
one of the anchors of the neighborhood
in any other year the euro cup is easy
business
open the doors and turn on the tv but
with capacity limits
co-owner rocco master angelo junior had
to get used to saying
no oh we're fully booked for today's
week
that changed as they got closer to the
final coveted rules were relaxed
and little italy roared back to life
yeah it's great
it's a great feeling you know i i feel
alive like i was
you know i was down and out for months
you know having
you know nobody here and then seemingly
overnight
everyone was it was a party that was
desperately needed
and it was really kind of a a sense of a
rebirth if you will where
we all got to feel like humans again you
know we're doing things that
we loved dearly we can all use some of
that
le dolce vita microlight global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is beta bird
newfoundland and labrador
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
we'll be back tomorrow and i'll see you
this weekend have a great night